deutschland steht vor dem corona herbst
die infektionszahlen steigen wieder
schneller
die 16 länderchefs und kanzlerin angela
merkel möchte und einen zweiten job down
vermeiden
gerade einmal drei stunden berieten sie
am dienstag und sie waren sich ziemlich
einig wie sie die zahlen wieder in den
griff bekommen können wir wollen
regional spezifisch zielgenau agieren
und nicht wieder sozusagen ein shutdown
für das gesamte land machen das muss
unbedingt verhindert werden
um das zu erreichen müssen wir sozusagen
mindestanforderungen haben für bestimmte
häufigkeiten von infektionen also keine
lockerungen die pflicht zur mund und
nase bedeckung in bestimmten bereichen
bleibt bestehen wird kontrolliert und
sanktioniert
außerdem wer falsche persönliche angaben
beim restaurantbesuch macht dem soll ein
bußgeld von mindestens 50 euro drohen
wir haben viel gelernt wir sind auch
recht gut durch den sommer gekommen
aber wir wissen dass vor uns die
schwierigere zeit liegt nämlich die
herbst und wintermonate und wir sehen
einen schrittweisen anstieg zum teil in
ballungsgebieten einen sehr deutlichen
anstieg an infizierten zahlen und das
ist natürlich ein grund zur beunruhigung
aber wir wissen auch dass wir dem uns
entgegenstellen können mit den richtigen
maßnahmen wurde infektionszahlen
ansteigen soll es zeitlich eingegrenzt
der alkoholverbote geben und bei privat
feiern wird die teilnehmerzahl
eingeschränkt und unser ziel ist also so
viel wie möglich von dem öffentlichen
und privaten leben aufrecht zu erhalten
und das bedeutet wenn hohe
infektionsraten auftreten eben auch
schnell zu handeln damit wir die dinge
auch dann sehr schnell wieder unter
kontrolle bringen immer regional
spezifisch apropos regional schleswig
holstein geht bei den strafen für
falschangaben in restaurants noch einen
schritt weiter ministerpräsident daniel
günther kündigte bußgelder von bis zu
1000 euro an
dagegen steht sachsen anhalt aus das
bundesland wird keine bußgelder
einführen weil es die kontaktlisten
gerade erst abgeschafft hat mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren